hi everyone today I'm going to tell you
about a new method called the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics or
Cindy which allows us to discover
governing equations for dynamical
systems purely for measurement data and
this is joint work with josh proctor and
nathan cuts and you can read more about
this online at PNAS or on the archive so
dynamical systems are a great way of
describing physical systems biological
systems really anything that changes in
time and if we have access to these
dynamical systems so the set of ordinary
differential equations X dot equals f of
X in some state vector X then there's
lots we can do with these dynamics so
for example I can integrate particles
through this differential equation or
integrate initial conditions X at time T
naught to some later time I can
integrate a grid of particles through
some fluid velocity field and there's
lots of things I can do like compute
coherent structures finite time ly
operative exponents uncertainty
quantification in this movie in the
lower right corner we're seeing fluid
flow past a rigid airfoil and we're
seeing these unsteady separate races
highlighted in red which are the time
varying analogs of stable and unstable
manifolds so lots we can do if we have
the dynamics X dot equals f of X but in
many physical systems like in
neuroscience or in climate science we
don't always have access to exact
differential equations describing the
system and so what we're going to want
to do is discover these dynamics from
measurement data and that's where this
sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics algorithm comes in so we're
going to illustrate this on a very very
simple toy system the Lorentz attractor
so we have the equations here for the
three variables XY and Z which describe
the evolution of this chaotic system and
notice that in the dynamics for X dots
the only terms active are y and X
so Sigma Rho and beta are constants in
the Y dot equation we have a linear term
and X a nonlinear term in XZ and a
linear term in Y and in the Z dot
equations we have a linear term in Z and
then the only non-linearity is this X Y
so in some sense these equations are
relatively simple out of the out of the
possible right hand side functions there
this has a very specific form with only
a few active terms and the non-linearity
so this will be important so what we do
is we run simulations of our system or
we collect measurement data from a real
experiment we collect the data in two
vectors x y and z so going down in time
and also x dot y dot and z dot and we'll
drop this condition that we need
derivatives and a little bit for but for
now let's assume we have XY and Z and
time X dot y dot Z dot in time as big
vectors and remember that out of all of
the possible right hand side functions
that these dynamics could take this is a
very specialized right hand side
function that tends to be quite sparse
and when I say sparse
I mean sparse in the space of possible
right hand side functions so now what we
do is from our data XY and Z we
construct vectors of all possible
polynomial nonlinearities up to order 5
so now we have just ones a vector of
ones a vector of X is wise and Z's we
also have x squared XY XZ y squared Y Z
Z squared and so on and so forth up
until Z to the fifth and what we're
going to do is apply some kind of a
regression to find which linear
combination of these non-linearity terms
represent X dot y dot and z dot ok
pretty simple idea but we're leveraging
the fact that these dynamics out of the
possible all possible right hand side
functions the actual dynamics for this
system and for lots of system happens to
be sparse so the way we set up this
regression we start with X dots so I
collect X dot measurements in time and
what I do is I do a sparse regression to
find the fewest the
linear combination of the fewest columns
of this library theta of X that are
needed to describe X dots and since X
dot was quite simple it's just constant
Y minus constant X this sparse
regression algorithm finds that all I
need are x and y features in some linear
combination and I don't need any of the
other terms in my nonlinear library so
sparse regression identifies the the
dynamics for the X dot equation and when
I say sparse regression there's lots of
things you can do here you could use the
lasso algorithm from tip shirani in our
paper we have an iterative sequential
least squares threshold inalca rhythm
that seems to work quite well also so
for the Y dot equation we do the same
thing we look at this vector of Y dot in
time and we look for what linear
combination of our nonlinear feature
vectors in this library theta are
necessary in some linear combination to
reconstruct y dot and lo and behold you
get an X term a Y term and an X Z term
which is exactly what our active in this
Y dot equation ok so there's no magic
going on here I'm just saying what
combination of you know X is y is YZ x
Squared's XY z-- X YZ and so on and so
forth are needed to represent y dot and
if I just did a least squares regression
I would get a little bit of all of these
columns in the fit and so I do this
penalize this l1 penalized sparse
regression so I get good regression fit
with as few nonlinear right-hand side
functions as possible and similarly you
can do this for Z dot and you get the
active terms in this dynamics so when
you put this all together you can find
this this nonlinear model on the right
in terms of these coefficients of which
terms in the nonlinear function space
are active and the identified system is
virtually identical it has the same
structure it has virtually the same
parameters Sigma Rho and beta and it
captures the dynamics on the attractor
ok so this is a relatively simple idea
and it takes advantage of the fact that
our dynamics if we may
in the right coordinates for example in
the lorentz system the right hand side
dynamics are sparse in the space of
possible right hand side dynamics or you
know in this case polynomials up to
order 5 ok now in principle we don't
want to have to measure XY and z and the
derivatives it seems too restrictive and
lots of systems you don't get to measure
the derivatives you just compute them
from XY and z and so we also have an
example where we have a really noisy
state measurements of the Lorenz
attractor so this is just a bunch of
noise on top of the Lorenz attractor so
we have noisy measurements of XY and Z
and for a surprisingly large magnitudes
of sensor noise we're able to compute
approximate derivatives using this total
variation derivative or TV diff this is
total variation regularized derivative
based on the total variation
regularization below and even with
tremendously noisy data and only having
measurements of XY and Z we're still
able to get very good structure
identification with Cyndi and a quite
accurate representation of the Lorenz
attractor and and dynamics on the
attractor so pretty cool that you don't
actually need to measure derivatives you
can have really noisy state measurements
and you can use this total regulation
total variation regularized derivative
in addition with some kind of a sparse
regression and both of these algorithms
are quite robust numerically and so they
give us great results even for for noisy
data okay so now I want to move on to a
more complicated and a more interesting
example problem and so this is the
example of fluid flow past a stationary
cylinder inducing vortex shedding and
this is this is a benchmark problem in
fluid dynamics and when we realize that
the Sindhi algorithm can predict a good
non-linear low order model for this
system we started to get really excited
because this is actually pretty close to
some research problems in fluid dynamics
so there's a nice bit of history here
and the
is kind of a rough sketch there's more
details but I want to paint this picture
that finding a low-order model for the
cylinder for vortex shedding past a
cylinder was not a simple task it took
decades of very bright people working
very hard to develop new theories so
discovering these dynamics would be
quite quite interesting so rural and
talk ins in 1971 proposed a Hopf
bifurcation route to turbulence where
you have a fluid system undergoing
sequential hop bifurcations and at some
point after a number of these Hopf
bifurcation the system becomes chaotic
and turbulent in fact this was proposed
earlier by Hoff himself and also by
Landau but the basic idea is that
there's the sight this idea that Hopf
bifurcation x' might be a route to
turbulence and chaos fifteen years after
rural and talk ins Zebub and Jackson and
others independently numerically
verified that in the cylinder wake
example as we increase the Reynolds
number or equivalently the oncoming flow
velocity as we speed up the flow past
the cylinder and at some critical
Reynolds number around 47 the system
goes through a Hopf bifurcation after
which you get periodic laminar vortex
shedding so about 15 years after this
rule Hawkins
paper there was numerical verification
that a Hopf bifurcation actually exists
in fluid systems which is great very
interesting but at the same time this
started getting this this created a real
paradox of sorts in that the hop normal
form or the the form of the
non-linearity required to get a Hopf
bifurcation are cubic right there's
cubic terms in a hop normal form whereas
we know that Navy or Stoke systems have
at most quadratic non-linearity due to
the connection terms so there was this
paradox how do I capture a third order
Hopf bifurcation phenomenon with a fluid
system that has quadratic nonlinearities
in the physics okay
so 15 years it took to find this Hopf
bifurcation
and it took 15 years later 15 more years
to find a solution to this the seeming
paradox of how you can get a Hopf
bifurcation with a quadratic system of
quadratic nonlinearities and so this was
discovered by no AK at all in jfm in
2003 and the idea here is that you could
have a separation of time scales
argument so I can have fast directions
in the flow and slow directions in the
flow so this Z variable here is a fast
variable in the the Z direction between
some unstable fixed point and the mean
flow of my vortex shedding and this Z
variable rapidly adheres on to this slow
parabolic manifold given by x squared Y
squared where x and y are the magnitude
of vortex shedding and once Z rapidly
kind of pulls on to this slow manifold
then it just wraps and wraps and wraps
until it gets periodic vortex shedding
in x and y okay so notice in X dot y dot
and z dot there's nothing but quadratic
nonlinearities but this system does
undergo a Hopf bifurcation and n
exhibits vortex shedding so this is a
beautiful theory roughly 30 years
progression a very very good work
finding these hot bifurcations and
explaining how you can get them with
quadratic nonlinearities very
interesting so we thought this would be
a great test system for our Sindhi
algorithm so now what we're gonna do is
we collect the exact same data just data
from a simulation of vortex shedding I
do some dimensionality reduction like
proper orthogonal decomposition to find
the mode that describe vortex shedding
and also this shift mode from the
unstable equilibrium to the mean flow
and I plug in those those coefficients
those three time series of p OD mode one
and two and shift mode into the cindy
algorithm and what's really amazing is
that we identify a system that has
structurally the same form
it only has quadratic nonlinearities
there is this slow parabolic manifold
and it captures this spiral onto vortex
shedding so very interesting that the
Cindy algorithm if you feed it purely
data from a numerical simulation will
back out the right the right form of the
dynamics purely with it'll discover
these quadratic nonlinearities and this
fast slow time scale separation so this
got us really excited that maybe we can
actually solve real problems with this
algorithm so it's really important to
note at this point that if I just take
measurements of my system on the slow
manifold so let's say I start somewhere
on the slow manifold and I wash the
system of all bun to vortex shedding the
Sindy algorithm incorrectly identifies
cubic nonlinearities and so what I
actually have to do is I have to kick my
system off the attractor so for example
I start at the mean flow the system
falls down and then winds back up again
or maybe I start out here the system
goes to the slow manifold and winds back
down but the the moral of the story is
to actually identify the correct
quadratic nonlinearities for this
problem we have to kick the system off
of the attractor and this is in general
a very important strategy when you're
identifying nonlinear dynamics of a
system that has some sort of attractor
is it's really important to kick off the
attractor to see how the system falls
back on without that we wouldn't be able
to identify the correct normal form here
and so this got us thinking that in
addition to identifying nonlinear
dynamical systems that a particular
value of a parameter like the Reynolds
number we can actually do parametrized
dynamics essentially for free okay so I
can look at a system X dot equals f of X
and a set of parameters mu where mu dot
are fixed they're zero and so here we
are looking at the logistic map so I
sample the logistic map at ten parameter
values or ten mu values and these light
blue locations I use that as the
training data so now instead of just
constructing columns of X x squared X
cube X to the fourth X to the fifth I
also treat mu
as a feature vector so I have mu X mu X
X squared mu x squared and so on and so
forth I have all of the combinations all
of the polynomial combinations of mu and
X and I do the same sparse regression
and identify not only the dynamics at
one parameter value but I actually get
the parametrized dynamics and so using
these ten training values we get a
parameterised model that you can then
evaluate at all parameters and you
generalize beautifully into this
logistic map kind of bifurcation diagram
that we're used to seeing you can also
do this on the hop normal form similar
to the vortex shedding example except
now we're actually sweeping through a
number of parameters in the hop normal
form and identifying the parametrized
system so very cool you can include
parameters mu you can include time as a
vector so I can have or maybe sine of
time or x squared or time X so I can
have time varying dynamical systems I
can also include forcing external
forcing from let's say I'm doing a
climate simulation and I've got co2
forcing I can include that as a feature
vector or control forcing like some some
state feedback okay so a couple of other
neat things I want to tell you so the
Sindhi algorithm is great it's based on
simple sparse regressions so it's very
extensible very powerful that lots of
things you can do with it
and so one of those things I'm going to
tell you about are how you use Sindhi
and time delay coordinates okay so in
our original Lorentz system and I get
this question a lot it's a great
question what if I only had access to
some subset of these primitive
measurement variables instead of XY and
Z what if I just had access to X okay
and we're not the first people to think
about this lots and lots of people think
about this problem where I have some
complicated systems and complicated
chaotic system and I have limited
measurements okay so maybe just X in the
lorentz system what do I do
and Wilson you still work so the short
answer is yes Cyndi still works and what
we end up doing in this case
is we take our time series of our
measurement X and we build up a Hankel
matrix where we essentially take X and
we take shifted copies of X so X 1 to X
P X 2 to X P plus 1 X 3 and X P plus 2
and so on so these are a time series I I
cut out the first P pieces of X and I
that's my first row then I take 2 to P
plus 1 that's my second row and so on
and so forth so I sift and stack my
single measurement in time into this
Hankel matrix H and if I take the
singular value decomposition of this
Hankel matrix I essentially get a set of
eigen delay coordinates or Augen time
series that best represent this
particular time series X and so if I use
the the columns of V as a new set of
generalized coordinates we can
beautifully reconstruct a topologically
equivalent attractor this is standard
kind of talk ins embedding theory here
that I can get an embedding in these
time delay coordinates with a single
measurement that is topologically
equivalent to the original Lorenz
attractor very cool and if I take those
three measurements so this is the first
column of V the second column of the
first column third column second column
third column so I'm taking the first
three eigen Time series from the SVD of
this Hankel matrix I plug those into the
Sindhi algorithm and I get a sparse
model that very very nicely reconstruct
the attractor so on the bottom we're
actually seeing the Sindhi model with
the same initial condition and it traces
out the same dynamics on this time delay
embedded attractor very cool you can do
time delay with Cindy if you have
limited measurements now it's also
interesting to note people of course
I've been looking at these time delay
systems for decades talking's embedding
Theory really got everybody excited
about this and I found this really nice
visualization of the same
basically rent system in these same
eigen time delay coordinates in broom
head and King from 1986 so people have
been looking at these SBDS or singular
value decomposition of the Heinkel
matrix in the context of singular
spectrum analysis SSA and climate
science or the eigen system realization
algorithm er a in control theory and
system identification but now we can do
this for nonlinear dynamical systems and
we actually get a nonlinear model out on
this time delay coordinates very cool so
the last thing I want to show you is
Cindy width control so lots of times
your dynamical system X dot equals f of
X is not just evolving in its natural
state but it's being externally forced
either through some exogenous
disturbance or forcing signal or through
some active feedback control maybe I'm
modifying the system deliberately and so
I have this plus G of U term here okay
and what this G of U allows me to do and
this G of U could be you know in X dot y
dot or Z dot or it could enter in all
three I just picked the first X dot
equation what this G of U does is it
allows me to have this control enter
possibly non linearly so G of U could be
U cubed or U to the fourth or sine of U
and u can be a nonlinear function itself
in this case I chose a state feedback
control 26 minus X plus some white noise
disturbance but it could be some
exhaustion is you know external forcing
or state feedback and it can enter a non
linearly so with the Sindhi algorithm
again if I build a feature library of
possible nonlinearities that are a
function of X Y Z and you now let's say
I measure you then I can discover these
dynamical systems from measurement data
okay so I can discover the dynamical
system plus forcing basically I use the
same code I just treat X Y Z and you as
my possible feature features that I'm
taking combinations of so here's an
example where we do Cindy with control
so from time 0 to 20
we have a training set of data that's
being controlled I measure XY and Z and
you and I'll earn my Cindy model I
learned this this sparse non linear
model with control and then at time 20
what happens is I switch from one
control protocol to another okay so the
original Cindy algorithm in yellow fails
miserably when I turn on a different
control law because it didn't original
Cindy didn't know there was external
forcing or feedback control but the new
Cindy with control in light blue
perfectly matches the new test data
because it learned the structure of the
dynamics how the control enters and so
if I give a different you a different
protocol for how to control you then
Cindy with control can track perfectly
the actual validation data so it's very
cool that you can identify not only the
nonlinear dynamical system but you can
also disambiguate the effective control
from the underlying dynamics and train a
system so that if you change your
control policy you can you can capture
it with this model okay
so just to summarize we have lots of
data we want dynamics there's lots of
cool things we can do when we have
dynamics or dynamical systems and so a
general procedure to go from data to
dynamics in this cindy or sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
frameworks first we measure we measure
what we have access to in a low-rent
system we try to measure XY and Z if we
only measure X we build time delay
coordinates but we measure then we find
some some basis where we can represent
the possible nonlinear dynamics that did
explain those measurements so in the
case of Lorentz I build a library of XY
and Z and also all of the other
polynomial nonlinearities up to Z to the
fifth so I build some representation for
those dynamics and then I use sparse
regression or lasso type type algorithms
to find the fewest of those nonlinear
features that are required to explain
the measurements and I get a sparse data
chemical system purely from measurement
data okay
so some of the issues that crop up some
other questions I get a lot are well how
do you know you measure the right things
this is a pretty important question
there's lots of interesting ways of
tackling that so for example the time
delay coordinate perspective gives you
some powerful tools to figure out am i
measuring enough variables are two
variables that I'm measuring correlated
do they give me new information there's
lots of a theory of am i measuring the
right thing in a dynamical system but
maybe a more difficult question is how
do I know that I'm using the right
nonlinear basis to represent my dynamics
right maybe maybe polynomial
nonlinearities aren't going to work for
my system maybe I need sines and cosines
maybe I need vessels functions maybe I
need rational functions and this is an
excellent point
so typically depending on the physics of
the system you have some idea or you
should have some idea of what are good
measurements and you should have some
idea of functions that might be
important to represent your dynamics so
for example if I'm doing Navy or Stokes
equations for fluids I know that I have
quadratic nonlinearities other systems
have different nonlinearities so it
gives you some guidance on how to
measure and how to build a possible
candidate nonlinear function basis but
in general we do recommend trying you
know try different different bases try
polynomials try trigonometric try other
bases and we do have new methods to
generalize to rational functions to
trigonometric functions and those will
be online soon and the regression is
perhaps the easiest step we have lots of
great tools numerically that are very
robust very stable for regression so
once you have good measurements and a
good representation a possible good
representation of the dynamics finding
the active terms the active
nonlinearities is in some sense the easy
part okay so with that I will conclude
you can read more again in PNAS thank
you very much